he'll write I love I love you went from
God's country to hell right there's
another there's another fun transition
of this project walking contradiction
since the day I came into this industry
well yeah you know we'll former Jesus
got a tight grip it's a tequila Sheila
oh this album makes perfect sense to me
I don't know about you just showed us
all sides right right that's right
that's part of it what you're the one
that said it what is it
country music is Saturday nights and
suddenly more that's it that's it we
like to party we like to drink but we
like to get up on Sunday morning and
have faith we don't like to will we get
up on Sunday mornings and do it cuz we
know we should right we've mentioned
nobody but you Gwynne of course things
with you on that collaboration what is
tell us and she came from the pop world
what's the country's thing about her
because you would know there's a there's
a photo of her when she was a kid with a
cowboy hat on holding two kittens s
that's about his country of a thing as I
can think but you know what she I tell
you what since we've been together
I mean this girl has literally fallen in
love with country music it's all that
she listens to it's all it's all in her
car and it's not to do with with me or
anything it's just she grew up in
Anaheim you know and then moved to Los
Angeles she just said she didn't hear a
lot of country music is all I'm saying
is her her parents abused her with this
other music they played it was music
abuse I'm telling you
music abuse but anyway so she just
wasn't exposed to you know a lot of
country music but now it's it's all it's
all she listens to you know I hope she's
okay with me saying that but it is
[Music]